make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Robin and
we are finally getting around to
covering DC stat wolves in number four
as you guys know if what we talked about
in the past the decease line of early
the the Hobart World's End line of
comics take place during the main DC
stories I'm still not sure exactly how
we're going to place these in terms of
the chronology in relation to the other
DC stories as far as like a playlist or
something like that
but I'll figure it all out and I'll make
sure that I have that set up for you
guys um I do have a playlist down in the
description for all the DC stuff if you
want to kind of follow along as we're as
we're covering all this but what this
does is this initially picks up with a
couple of different things the first is
a place called Jotunheim and the second
is the Eyrie as well as wink now
Jotunheim is a it's really kind of like
a building where a fortress of sorts
that was made in DC Comics that was made
during World War Two by the Germans but
the idea is that it's designed to be a
fortress that's virtually impenetrable
and for the most part it is right you've
got a little tiny door down at the
bottom that you can use to access it but
it's not from that there's no real
conceivable way to break in there
through traditional means now as far as
the eerie and wink go these are two
exceedingly new characters eerie and
wink first appeared in Suicide Squad
volume 6 issue number one and February
of this year in 2020 and we don't really
know anything about them it's kind of
weird eerie refers to itself as like
it's dry doesn't really call himself
like I or like him or she so I don't
know like it's kind of it's almost
referred to as if eerie is like two
people combined into one but eerie and
Winker basically just coming together
here now the fact that Tom Taylor
includes these characters in here is
part of what's going on with deceased is
really I think nothing more than to kind
of advertise characters that he has
going on in Suicide Squad and to kind of
be like hey guys like if you want to see
more of these characters check out
Suicide Squad I can't really think of
much much reason why you would see them
there in this but the long and short of
this is that with Erie's ability to fly
that he's really just kind of been
moving and moving them in a particular
location but you've also got wink who
has the ability to teleport now the
reason why I think winks not really
teleporting too much is it seems like
there's a kind of limitation here and it
makes sense in a sense that wink seems
to have the ability to teleport but only
the places that she's either seen or she
understands the layout of now as soon as
they get to where yo Dan hymens they're
immediately set upon by fire right like
they literally started start getting
shot at all over the place now at that
point wink teleports and then retail at
ports them inside of Jotunheim itself
and then immediately calls for a
ceasefire and that it's kind
intriguing because on the surface you
kind of have this idea that like these
guys are kind of in effect quote-unquote
villains but the reality of this is that
if you guys are following deceased
you've got heroes out there who are
incredibly powerful who have been
infected right so it's one of these
things where like anybody who's not here
is gonna be treated as a bad guy it's
the safest thing to do that's how you
keep people safe because as soon as you
start letting people in you're gonna let
the wrong ones in while you're gonna let
infected people in and there goes your
entire base of operations hard times
require hard decisions and so from here
we basically end up jumping over to the
fortress of solitude right now this
takes place before Damien officially
takes on the mantle of Batman and in
fact this suit has just been given to
him by Alfred I mean this is not
something that we got to see a whole lot
of and even here we don't really get to
see a whole lot of it it's only you know
one or two pages but it's Damian Wayne
just kind of struggling with the idea of
taking on the mantle of Batman right
because for all the vaunted pride of
Damian and all I kind of stuff the idea
of what Batman means and what it
represents was not lost on him sure he
had like a rough relationship with his
dad
right I mean Damian kind of grew up and
was taught was taught to be a
cold-blooded killer and then when he was
handed over to Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne
tried to ease some of those sharper
edges Damian had and it certainly led
into a whole lot of bumping of head
between these two guys but by and large
Damian understands the notion of what it
means to be Batman the responsibility
that comes with taking on such a mantle
and so does Jonathan right Jonathan kind
of makes that makes that makes us come
and yell the symbol doesn't exactly come
free of burden when you take on that
symbol when you take on that mantle you
take on all the responsibility that
comes along with it and so we get this
really cool moment here in a second but
before we do I want to switch back over
to wink and to the Eyrie because
basically you end up having just like
Manticore who's the guy with the lion's
head it's kind of a weird character he
had Manticore way back in the day in the
old ostrich nursery so I'd squad stories
he was part of a group called jihad he
was never really that important and then
you have him now and he's still not
important but he's in this story right
so I guess it served some kind of a
purpose but basically says that if the
agreement of wink and and the Eyrie was
that will help you if you guys need it
as long as you give us quarter then he
comes in and basically says now's the
time for your help right we had two
members of our team who basically went
to scout to the west they haven't
returned go look for let's see if you
can't figure out what it was that
happened to him either they become
infected or they're just stranded out
there somewhere and they're looking for
rescue whatever the case is we need
answers from you and so despite the
eerie having virtually no sleep he ends
up jumping in and doing what needs to be
and so at this point we switch over to
Superman and this is where Tom Taylor
really shines Tom Taylor is one of these
riders where he's so remarkably good at
focusing on characters capturing
characters the way they're supposed to
be and then giving them to us in these
ways that are exceedingly interesting
right it's why the story of of injustice
gods among us were so good is because it
didn't have anything to do with like
Superman becoming a bad guy Batman
becoming a rebel fighter or anything
like that it was the breakdown of the
characters why they were doing what they
were doing Tom Taylor was exceedingly
good at that and that's what we end up
getting here with Damian Wayne Damian
Wayne's initial question for first
Superman is like shouldn't you be out
there any responses yeah but like
Jonathan wanted me to come in here and
he said this was more important and so
it's kind of cool because they have this
this interesting conversation like
Superman says that that Bruce Wayne
believed that Damian deserved this right
it's not something that Damian was just
given because of the fact there is no
Batman Damian's the only real Robin left
and so he just gets the suit because
there's just no other options Damian's
getting it because Batman wanted him to
have it and is one of these things where
Damian says well Bruce wasn't always
right the response of a Superman is well
you know of course not I mean it's
that's kind of ridiculous but when were
kids we don't understand what it is that
our fathers are trying to teach us it's
only when we grow older that we begin to
understand what it was that they were
saying and it's like that in life right
like for our parents right girls moms
tell their daughters don't go after the
bad boys and the daughters do it anyway
then they grow up and realize yep their
moms were right fathers tell their sons
don't go after the easy girls right like
you're gonna get nothing with problems
they're right and there's kind like
whatever pops you don't know what you're
talking about they grow up then they
realize that's right you see that in all
manner of different different ways don't
chase the easy money go for things that
work hard expand your possibilities get
out there in lift we get all these
different explanations from our parents
about how it is that we should live our
lives in the most effective way possible
and for the most part we have a tendency
when were younger to kind of blow them
off because they don't know what they're
talking about or they're from like a
bygone era things have changed whatever
the case is but then as we grow up and
as we become adults we come to this
realization that they're right they were
instilling in us the wisdom is best that
they could offer and they weren't
entirely wrong and that's one of the
things a Superman basically tells to -
Damian Wayne that yes your father wasn't
always right but your father was trying
to help you become the best version of
yourself and because of that if he if he
believed that you deserved to have the
Batman mantle then he was right about
that but it was his it was his call he
was Batman
besides who becomes the best person and
he decide to that person's going to be
based on what it is if he knows now the
other part of this and this is what's
kind of interesting here this question
you have to ask what if Damian had died
I could imagine that conversation with
like with Dick Grayson here you go to
Dick Grayson here's a Batman students
like man Bruce Wayne really wanted me to
have this well no he really thought
Damian was the one who should have it
but Damian's dead so like you get to
have it now because you know there's no
other option at this point it'd be kind
of disheartening it'd be a pretty
disheartening conversation but still
Damian's biggest struggle here with
regards to putting on the Batman suit is
the fact that if he does if he dons the
mantle of the Batman suit if he puts it
on he attaches all the gear he goes to
that whole process and he's officially
recognized as Batman then it means one
absolute and irrevocable truth Bruce
Wayne is gone there's no means for him
to come back and as one of these things
were it's not tied to a suit it's just
this realization the truth of this is
that Bruce Wayne is gone right Bruce
Wayne is not going to come back right
there's no indication that Bruce Wayne's
somehow survived or anything like that
one of the first things that was done in
deceased is Bruce Wayne was killed right
you guys remember that issue number one
Bruce Wayne's dead and it was kind of
mind-blowing at the time because our
experience with regards to Batman and
Plot armor is that well he'll find a way
to live because you know it's Batman he
always makes it out but he didn't and it
was awesome to see a story and what a
story can be if Batman doesn't make it
right like it really kind of lends
credence to the idea that Batman doesn't
need to be the focal point of every
major story that you see but it's one of
these things that Damian's kind of
struggling with and at the end of the
day Superman's response is the world
needs a Batman there are people out
there who are struggling there are
people out there who are having a hard
time of it right who are literally
fighting for their lives your father
became a superhero because of the fact
that he lost people that he cared about
you're in the same boat you lost someone
that you cared about multiple people
that you care about is your chance to
become a hero to step into that role and
to continue the legacy of Batman and so
as this suit begins to get put on
Damian's kind of nervous Pat he's like
it doesn't quite feel right and so on
there's a couple changes that are made
here and there but then he full-on
becomes Batman and so effectively Batman
has now returned and so what we do is we
end up jumping back directly to link and
to the earring and the idea here is of
course they're basically scouting by the
eerie kind of looks around in the end so
on and when he's asked by wink what is
it you see the eerie looks forward and
basically sees this enormous army right
measuring in what appears to be the
hundreds of
thousands that are all being led by a
man who flies and as Erie gets a better
view we end up finding out this is black
Adam the black Adam being infected is
now leading the anti-life army it's
pretty cool right like the anti-life
army rises here this is awesome because
immediately the Erie panics right he
basically goes back to Rincon he's like
we've gotta warn Jotunheim we've got to
get back there tell them what's going on
there's an army of undead coming here
and black Adam is more than enough to
bring this entire facility crashing down
if we don't leave we're going to die but
with that being said guys we're gonna be
in this video to an end if you are new
here two comments explain and make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the rod for if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a light
that will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you